okay so check this out watch this video
this is what just happened to in
australia and and when i posted this i
said can somebody verify this this is a
guardian video that they have go ahead
joe would be impressed with that kick
right there that's your tax dollars at
work australia
australians are funding that with the
hours of their lives
yeah what are you doing now watch what
the guy says
yeah but you're choking you're choking
her there's a man on the go as a man on
a girl it's a man on a girl and you
choked her
but what for a mask for not having a
mask look how pathetic she doesn't have
a mask are you serious are you serious
just for not having a mask
are you [__] serious this is a
disturbing video by the way so folks if
you watches that's a let's call george
that issue adishi from um
uh uh australia okay
uh uh
let's see if george if you're speaking i
he's picked up so i don't know if you
guys can hear him on our because i
cannot
yeah good morning gents george how are
you
good good patrick so brother can you
take a second tell us your background
like five seconds your background and
tell us what's going on in australia
yeah look i um like to
i i was actually born in sydney um lived
there for probably the first 35 years of
my life and then actually i've had to
move into state for work but um
yeah i in the uh i'm i'm
i guess one of the fortunate ones more
in the white collar and in a good area
but um not feeling the same for
the rest of the family unfortunately um
yeah sydney's sydney in particular has
been in shambles uh locked up i think
it's in week 15 now
where you're not able to actually travel
longer than i think about five
kilometers
away from home
um
yeah they're rewarding some industries
over here with uh you know you can only
work but if you if you're double jabbed
so that's um
that's that's caused some issues but
it's rewarding some people are not
others and then you've got areas also in
some of the more affluent areas in
sydney which are not being really
enforced the rules where you know places
you know that are considered more
blue-collar have the army
and uh you know high-level police
tactics units
patrolling the streets making sure that
people are living by the rules so george
the video we saw this is not everywhere
in australia this is just pockets so so
let me let me give you maybe optics for
us in the state so in america
california and new york we know how
they're doing new york governor
yesterday announced that they're going
to be firing the unvaccinated health
workers and nationals guard's going to
come out and a lot of people are leaving
new york a lot of people are leaving
california and some are going to texas
some are going to arizona some are going
to greenwich some are going to dc some
are going to florida some are going
tennessee they're going all over the
place what states are more like the new
york and california of australia and
what areas are more like the texas and
florida of australia
yeah no good question so the um the
places that are more like california are
places like victoria so melbourne a lot
of people would know melbourne
uh is one of the sort of um very similar
to california
and um sydney unfortunately wasn't like
that previously but it's it's actually
turned more
more uh
more liberal i guess if you want to use
that term
um the places where people are moving to
are generally more north so places like
queensland so you've got a big influx of
people moving into brisbane and gold
coast
um
which are like the more warmer areas and
a little bit more freedom uh to move
around and do what you want
how how bad are in
are things in those areas where
you said a more liberal how bad are
things like how how are they uh you know
you hear stories about lockdown you've
not been able to leave your house for
eight weeks 12 weeks
you know we read about it but we're not
in australia to know what's going on
what would you say is really happening
over there for some of us that are not
in australia
yeah look it's
i guess what they're trying to force at
the moment is compliance and so even
people who don't or have been
traditionally against
uh you know the recent job um
you know are being forced to to do so
only because it means that they have to
put food on the table so as you
mentioned before
but there are
you know if you're not if you don't have
the job companies are giving you a
deadline they're saying if you don't
have it by for example the fifth of
october uh you'll be automatically
resigned from your position and you'll
need to find employment elsewhere so
they're they're saying they're giving
you a choice but they're not really you
know they're saying they're saying to
you well the choices here is either take
the job and go against your principles
or don't put food on the table
and so a lot of people are saying well
we have to make the sacrifice we need to
put a roof over our heads and you know
feed our families
so we're going to have to
you know have to take it is there major
protesting going on or no are people
just kind of sitting back and
are too concerned that if they push back
too much something could happen to them
and their families
yeah no it's um so there have been
protests um specifically in victoria uh
in melbourne which is probably where
you've seen
some of the heavy-handed tactics there
new south wales as well
has also had protests but the police
have done a really good job of actually
finding
some of the ringleaders and finding them
quite severely and putting others in
jail um you know some of the fines here
are very expensive so you know for those
that aren't already working then having
to
to fork out money for a fine is
you know it's it's heartbreaking for a
lot of what kind of fines are we talking
about
oh it's you know five thousand dollars
five five thousand dollars we're not
getting vaccination
no i don't know for out for out
protesting so you know trying to you
know protesting for you know giving a
lot of these people are already
vaccinated and but but what they're
protesting is you know people to have
free will to have the ability to choose
whether to take or not to take so
you know unfortunately
the police are doing a good job of
ensuring that
you know people aren't out there
protesting and we're not hearing we're
only hearing what's happening in the
mainstream media a lot of the protests
you know what you mentioned earlier is
they're actually being restricted from
being put on social media so unless if
you're actually at the protest or you
know someone directly at the protest
you're not hearing about it you're not
finding out about
what's happening on the streets the
heavy-handed tactics you'll see a lot of
the
the media uh is actually being
you know you know taken the videos are
being taken by individuals who are then
posting it up um onto more of the uh the
freedom
you know the free kind of social media
george this is uh adam i was like
actually going to ask you that exact
question there's a good friend of mine
who lives in sydney he's keeping me very
informed of what's going on there's i
guess there's a journalist verified in
australia sophie ellsworth
she said this is talking about melbourne
that from today's
protest no live vision
of melbourne's protest will be allowed
to be aired a directive of the victoria
police which has been deemed a form of
media censorship so my question is
where are you seeing all this stuff
what's going on in the media is it on tv
is it on social media or friends passing
it's around
the fact that they won't even show
protests
that's i mean that's some big brother
stuff right there what are your thoughts
yeah yeah
yeah no adam it's it's definitely
friends passing it on to other friends
um it's not you're definitely not seeing
it on mainstream media or you're not
seeing it on the the main networks uh
it's friend passing it on to a friend
who is passing it on to another friend
that that's the only way you're able to
see some of the live footage have you
had any interaction with police or
anything like that that have been
disturbing or your friends have been
like the one video we saw the of the
lady getting choked out because she
didn't have a mask do you have any
stories like that or your friends have
any stories like that
yeah no definitely have not not myself
personally but um like for direct
friends of mine um who've been who've
actually been arrested and taken to
court for you know refusing to follow
police instructions and um you know
sometimes they're enforcing rules so the
rules are sort of on and off all the
time you know like um for example up in
queensland at the moment um the rules
the the mask wearing rules have been
more strictly enforced uh because we've
had three new capers up in up in
queensland what percentage of
australians agree with this tactic it it
would i would see assume it's
a decent majority or a decent number if
they're allowing this what are your
thoughts
uh i wouldn't say adam i mean it's it's
unfortunately it's the the silent the
silent minority that are making a lot of
the noise so
um yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't say and
we're sort of following a lot of what
the minority are doing
uh or want us to do can you give us a
procedure
australian
oh look i'd say i'd say it's probably
about
it it might be 40 60 so 40 percent want
these quick rules and the other 60 just
want to be left alone to do their own
thing um but all we're hearing is about
the forty percent
and what on what they want has coveted
actually uh declined meaning are they
actually making progress with fewer
cases and fewer deaths
uh uh in regards to cobit
uh
last last year in 2020 we didn't hear
about too many deaths um
you know where it was sort of young
people i think the average age of uh
people dying from covert up here in or
down here in australia is i think it's
in the 80s
so it's it's hard to it's hard to say
patrick if it's crazy if they're covered
type yeah their covert type deaths or
their uh you know deaths from other
from other uh
thank you so much for for taking the
time by the way to help us you know
understand this on a global scale i know
we have a lot of listeners out there
that are that are very confused
um the the quarantine camps out there do
you know anybody that's been inside of
the quarantine camps what it's like out
there is this something that that
uh it has been over reported under
reported can can you give me any idea on
on uh what that situation is like where
there are actual
camps where they're taking people who i
suppose have have tested positive or
actually in in some cases from one i've
read haven't tested positive they've
just been around people who have tested
positive and they've been removed from
society and put in these camps for weeks
at a time
yeah it's it's definitely underreported
we don't we don't hear too much about it
i think what they did is a few months
ago they did actually ask you know they
did put it out into mainstream media and
i don't think the
the feedback was overly positive so we
haven't really heard too much about it
since
um yeah they're really controlling the
narrative there yeah by the way i just
looked at the number kai if you go to
statistia
and you type in i typed in the following
search i typed an average age of covet
that's uh in australia and if you go
down to the statistia website
uh
if you go average average it's right
there age of covid
um
deaths in uh
australia you got to go to australia
okay
why you guys are bringing that up we're
actually finding out later down the
track
um after the media is reported we've had
you know for example one death in one
part of sydney you're actually finding
out later that that person actually
didn't die from covert where they may
have had cover for the time but that
historical heart issue for example or
they were cancer patients and so it's
it's hard to tell
them yeah they did they die from covert
or do they die with poverty it's it and
they've tried to make that distinguish
yeah they've tried to distinguish right
by the way right here if you look at
this the statistic statista
shows that number of covadets that took
place
by age majority are over 90 and over 80.
look at the and then over 70. and look
at the drop off when you go to 60 and
below wait wait are those in the
thousands or is that 200 200 people
number of people she was on september
2017.
that would be the number of people
number two 100 people in a there's 25
million people in australia
and that's over 80 just over the age of
80. this is september 2021. so if you if
you calculate this male and females say
that's 210
say that's 450. say that's 350. so say
800 a thousand 1100 right there and then
you have at the bottom here is say uh a
hundred say a hundred
out of the twelve hundred people that
have died
are under the age of seventy yeah older
and then ninety percent of people that
died are above the age of and they and
they can't go out after nine o'clock at
night the entire country is locked down
on military law george let's uh maybe uh
try to think positive i guess in three
weeks from now uh apparently on october
18th there's something going to be
called freedom's day and apparently
that's when 80 percent of the population
will be fully vaccinated and apparently
your
airports are going to be open for the
first time in two years i guess uh
fourth quarter of this year what do you
know about this freedoms day and this 80
percent uh yeah benchmark stay strong
there george the first nine months of
two weeks to flatten the curve of the
hardest buddy
yeah
yeah now look it's um
it's it's a carrot adam
but the carrot's been moved a few times
um so i'll believe it when i see it
unfortunately um but yeah they've
there's there's a few times they've made
promises when we get to 70 and then they
moved it to 75 into 80 so
who knows but if when we get to 80 it
might then become 85 we just don't know
um
well george appreciate you buddy
brother thank you for surviving
thank you uh just two two things pat
just to finish off first of all
obviously happy birthday to dylan thank
you um you know wish you all the best
and also i want to wish my son jonah
happy seventh birthday as well
jonah happy birthday buddy by the way
it's also rose's birthday it's also
gerard's birthday today and today is
also gerard's birthday and like what a
special day by the way jonah happy
birthday to you gerard and rose
george once again thank you for your
time brother happy birthday all around
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you adam wanted to leave him on a
positive note and i'll leave him on a
positive note to all the great people of
australia i've never met a single
australian in my life that wasn't
awesome by the way man the great people
australia there are 65 000 police
officers on that island there are 25
million 0.5 million australians apes
together strong
yeah you know you you teed them up to
give you them some hope and then they
just keep pushing that that
that that little why wouldn't they tom i
know
dude guys the whole world and this goes
back to what i was talking about about
before pat were you talking about be a
synergist and and i get that i really
really do but some points somebody's got
to be a catalyst they will not they're
not going to stop
they're not going to stop you have to
force them to stop so if you enjoy this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]